oh good morning John it's that space
between Christmas and New Year's where
no one knows what's going on and I
almost forgot to make a video I just
texted me she said should I come down
and I was like I'm doing the puzzle well
I could use another set of hands it's
too bad you can't see it it looks great
right in this direction in lair of ours
no the first question is for Mandy who
asks if you fart in space could the
sound propagate through its gas you
would both have to be out of spacesuits
and dying and your ear would have to be
very close to their persons but but I
bet you could yeah
well the nice thing is you don't have to
be alive to fart you do have to be alive
to hear things that's the nice thing you
can still fart when you're dead they
call it the Lord's - the last one you
have no they don't
are you excited to be a part cunny
excited to do a live to eat this Kathryn
to do a live delete this Hank you
therapist you're gonna be fine okay what
holiday music do you guys like to listen
to and also Handel's Messiah okay it's a
mix in this household Julian would like
to know what the sequel to an absolutely
remarkable thing will be named I have a
name that I'm calling it I've been told
that it's bad by my publisher and editor
and agent this Gavin's reaction I told
her what it was yeah I get I mean no
renter wants to know do we remind each
other of anybody from like characters
from books or movies oh great because I
look like I look like Ralph fair I mean
mr. Darcy
nothing like Fitzwilliam I was thinking
Duane Duane bevy wants to know what's
your favorite thing about my Twitter
what's my favorite thing about your
Twitter mm-hmm Wow nothing my favorite
weebs that I've weaved
you don't know what we're talking about
listen to our podcast delete this delete
this um it's free recorded right here in
this room right here right on that couch
over there yeah usual usually sometimes
from our bed though do you have any new
year's resolution I would like to use my
phone less mmm in my bed in English I
want to do a month meat-free oh yeah
start out the year
Oz I've never tried to go vegetarian
I've always thought that I should have
never done it I just want to try it out
what do you have to eat those hello
fresh is pretty quick all I wants to
know what our favorite inside couple
joke is we're not going to tell you
that's ours Gavin do you like pina
coladas and getting caught in the rain
absolutely not I don't like either of
those things
what's the cutest thing Oren has ever
done left him in his crib after he got
him up from his nap mm-hmm because he
likes to just spend a little time in
there by himself and I gave him a book
to look at he and then I went out into
his room I saw him like get his hippo
which is his lovey and like put it on
his lap and say hippo read book how
nervous are you for when your child
starts watching YouTube
oh very do you have any new year's well
wishes for people Katherine pup kept her
gonna say something did you just don't
understand Nutcracker whatever you need
to hear is what this Nutcracker is
saying John I'll see you on Tuesday I
think happy new year
tickets are available pod con right now
January 19th and 20th in Seattle
Washington there's also digital
attendance available it right under your
podcast out everything that happens a
pod con is a podcast it's true